nous sommes dans une période compliquée
de crise sanitaire mondiale et la
martinique n'est pas épargné depuis
l'annnonce prévu du déconfinement le 11
mai à venir et nous faut nous préparer à
vivre ensemble dans l'espace public et
vivre ensemble dans l'espace public va
imposer que nous puissions disposer de
masques barrières pour nous permettre de
circuler côtoyé nos amis nos voisins la
famille en les protégeant et en nous
protégeant nous mêmes la ville du
lorrain pour nous permettre de vivre ce
nouveau schéma de vie qui va s'ouvrir à
nous nous lançons un appel à solidarité
locale pour fabriquer des masques
lavables et réutilisables et nous avons
intitulé cette opération sept mille
masques pour les lots rhinois pour
réussir cet appel à solidarité
nous faisons appel à des bénévoles à des
couturiers et couturières qui souhaitent
nous rejoindre dans cette dynamique nous
faisons appel à des chefs d'entreprise
qui ont envie de faire un don des dons
allez sur le site de la ville vous
verrez les modalités pratiques que nous
avons institué une fiche le numéro
téléphone une adresse mail et dites nous
comment vous voulez participer à cet
appel à solidarité locale
ne restez pas confiné à partir du 11 mai
prenons notre destin en main fabriquons
des masques pour la solidarité des
lobbys droit